mike is with us in columbia missouri to
start this hour hey mike what's up
hey dave first off i want to say um
listen to your show for a while and it's
changed my life
so thank you for that thank you i'm
honored
yeah kind of facing a decision now i'm
kind of looking to make a change in my
career
and i'm looking at two jobs both of them
are paying a little better than i'm
making now um but
the one kind of on the lower side
it has a better location
i kind of it has just a lot of
intangibles that are great about the job
as far as a good boss
be a part owner in the company
but on the other hand i have another
high-paying job that
uh the location's kind of up in the air
it's a bigger company and there's
probably more room for advancement
um i just wanted to see kind of what you
thought about that
as far as what does each one pay
um the lower paying job pays about 80
000
and the higher paying job i could
probably
within two or three years probably make
double that okay
um doing what in each case
um they're sort of in the sales industry
so you're so you're a sales guy
yeah sales and consultants yeah okay
so the intangibles must be pretty
stinking high for you to be willing to
take half pay
yeah um like you said it's kind of my
dream location
the the boss is a really successful guy
and
i think yeah
i don't really care about his success
i'm worried about yours
yeah unless you're 23 and you're going
to put in two years and learn from
an extraordinary mentor is going to
carry along the way and you can have
somewhere to go
yeah how old are you yeah i'm 24.
okay all right so is that your idea
you're thinking you can
kind of write you can learn from this
guy because he's a he's a butt kicker
um i think that's part of it and then
yeah the location is
i i want to live there it might be more
exciting
there's something else here what's the
what's the the thing you're not saying
are you looking for permission to not
take this job that you don't really want
it's going to pay a lot um
i don't know i guess what's the location
what's the location of the
of the underpaid one that's so that's so
appealing
um it's so i would be in training
um kind of around the columbia area and
then it's
up in the air where i would go it's been
thrown out georgia
that's the eighty thousand different
locations no that's the higher page
okay what about the one that's got the
great location where's the great
location in columbia
it's no it's in the pacific northwest
black wire like seattle area
okay so you want to move to seattle
uh that's appealing to that area that's
appealing to you
yes why
i like the outdoors and you know it's
nice to be able to kind of go in your
backyard and
it's all there and go fishing after work
and different things which i know you
can do in georgia that's just not the
same
it sounds like you're putting a lot of
pressure on yourself to make a forever
decision you're 24 years old man
and if you were telling me that hey i've
got the opportunity to work
for dave ramsey for two years learn the
ins and outs of this thing
and he's going to take me along on the
ride and
then i'm gonna have skill set uh uh i'm
gonna have to get
a ringside seat to a world-class leader
and then i'm gonna have him on my
uh as a reference the rest of my life
yeah dude i'll
i'm gonna be real rude for a second go
make the money i'm gonna be rude for a
second
okay if you're coming to work for me and
you want to move to franklin tennessee
and the reason you want to come to work
for me is cause you can go fishing
i don't think i want you
well i i also like i mean it's in my
industry and it would be um
it'd be like more responsibility and it
would be more
um i would just have the freedom to do a
lot more in the company
and and you know help the company make
money you grew up in colombia
didn't you uh
yeah i've moved all over the country
doing different different things i work
for a large
contractor oh so see okay
all right i i um
okay here's the only way i know to help
you answer the question because i'm just
confused about this
call yeah me too um the um
what a good way to do this is to john
was onto something there
it's not forever but do ask yourself the
question
what do you want to be doing when you're
34
10 years from today and where do you
want to be doing it
and what kind of money do you want to be
making and what kind of a career field
do you want to be in and all those kinds
of things
and once you identify that ask yourself
the question which of these
takes you there and the love of the
great outdoors
i'm sorry that's way down the freaking
list of the discussion on this
because if you make 160 versus 180 you
can buy an
airline ticket well especially for if
you're a salesman for the amount of time
you're going to be able to get out and
go fishing
what i'm telling you if you're my friend
if you're my son
i'm telling you at 24 years of age you
are starting to grind brother go make
your money go to a place where you can
have a lot of influence you're going to
learn a lot
and georgia is a beautiful wonderful
place to live and as dave said man go
spend a few weeks in the great
northwest um but man get that
stuff under your belt and then you have
a lot more options when you're 34 and 44
and 54.
yeah but but which of these decisions
takes you to where you want to be
10 years from now and that'll get you
off the short term of oh
i don't want to live here ooh ooh and
this guy's a nice guy
none of that takes you where you want to
be ten years from now
and so the the the decision-making
variables
in this are disturbing and i can't put
my finger on exactly why i'm gonna guess
if we were to sit down and
have some coffee with this person
there's a romantic interest at one of
these places
that has a or a mom and dad interest at
one of these places well that's why i
asked if he grew up in columbia sound
like he's trying to get out of there
ah gotcha get out of the south yeah i
gotta get away yeah you know i'm getting
away from
crazy family or something i don't know i
don't know what's going on i can't put
my finger up but good luck with it dude
look out ten years and ask yourself
which of these is going to take you
there and hopefully that'll help you
answer the question better than these
two goofballs did and she'll go with you
trust me
yeah she'll come find you if she's worth
it or you'll go back and buy an airline
ticket or whatever however that works
huh
i think we overthink stuff dave he's 24
years old he's getting around
the mouth man listen yeah you don't you
know where are you going to college
so and so why my girlfriend's going
there bad plan
warning warning